Facilities
[Music]
I'm going to be bought
!  I'm going home pretty
Enkemine What the
hell is
this?  I
'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm fine
Oh, thank
you,
how are you
?
I have a feeling I don't
remember anything else.
That guy, what happened a while ago was abnormal.
- Even after the storm, a
mystery was brought along
with Matsushima.  seems to have lost his memory, and
until I introduce him to your company and obtain information, I would like him to stay here for the time being.
Personally, I wanted to hear about the future, but if you really slipped back in time,
I remembered something big on this island.
Say 3, you're someone who has an unknown amount of confidence
. You are, but at least
you're not from this island.
There are various things,
well, I'll give you that dress as a gift, so I'm grateful for that point.
I can't
say brass
more
than a little.
Don't let out a loud hoodie, you've been waiting for a waterfall.
I'm seriously sorry, so if you want to hit me, do as much as you like, but I don't mind if
you're there.
I was going to become
you, but you seem to have drifted to Ford, right?
It depends on what you did to your daughter
.
I don't have a body or a person,
minutes  What kind of song is
Option 9 c Your place
?
It won't disappear, but I'll look for it even in the fiscal year.
Did you know that I was recruiting for a
voice essay?
It's okay,
ah, I remembered my name is a facility
.
3000 times It's a
facility, but it's a felony
[music]
We know 7 people, but I
don't know, but
you know that moment  But I don't know about you, so be
careful. That's Nobunaga's pressure point line, 5 million,
4 characters.
The name of the island More than that, it
's true that it has transcended
time.I only remember the warehouse.I'm a time traveler.You
don't have to believe it.
I drowned in the sea and I have no memory of what happened before that,
so let's look for it together The momentary forgotten
mother A
new maid has arrived, right?
Oh
tue,
this is your room
.
Aren't you just falling in love with me in a
place like this
?
Toast, fried eggs, and cup soup are fine,
I don't need them anymore, so I'm going to sleep
.  A child of wisdom, strength, and courage who came from a country in the future after I died
Is it true that such information is spreading?
This is an important story about destiny. This
is my displeasure on the 4th. Urashima Library Swordsman
Urashima Shrine Temporary Office
What is this
?  I
don't know for sure, but I have a feeling that you are an
acquaintance of mine. No, it's the first time I've met you.
Did you let the flowers of love bloom from that day on
?  That's right,
Setsuna-san, you seem to have lost your memory.
I
can't identify
who it is, but my hypothesis is being proven because of Rinne-san's spirited away five years ago during your time travel
this time
.  Along with that, a mystery was brought about.
Perhaps a singularity occurred, and under its influence, the elementary particle enemy was transformed and flung into the past.
Ah, I don't need to say much. Will
it be useless after a few minutes?
th Nihon Univ.
th
[music]
Bach,
you've attacked me a lot because of that
, because I'm destined to save this island.
I will definitely give you my life with a honey trap, so the moment you say it, you're
bankrupt
.
It's full of mysteries,
and it's new.
Federation
Whoa,
what's
wrong where
are you going?
[music]
ana
me
[music]
oha
What's wrong
?
It's strange,
I'm sorry for the change I'm sorry for the
sadness
Thank you for your support in this world yeah
me
n ame
Everyone except nanea
ani
tee
hey hey
asan
me
n ame
[music]
ana
ha
[music] It's
good
[music]
me
n ame
me me
ran
me
[music]
ni
can
ni One day
[music] I
don't regret it  I want it
[music]
dea
tan